abandon your mission and head to ep
this is the western united states and
according to scientists
this is the result of climate change
wildfires have been a part of life in
this part of the country
but scientists say not like this not
this early
not this intense not this many fires
in oregon the bootleg fire scorching
more than one thousand five hundred
square kilometers of land
roughly the size of los angeles
happening in a state
that has already seen its share of
weather challenges in february
we saw devastating ice storms over a
half a million people lost
power last fall as you are well aware
we had unprecedented wildfires
we had over 4 000 homes lost in that
fire
and it is literally climate change
playing out before our eyes
the fires in oregon are so intense that
they are creating their own weather
systems
producing massive dry thunderstorms with
lightning and strong winds that can
start more fires
this is just one of dozens of fires
burning throughout the american west
and there is a major shortage of
firefighters
prison inmates are often used to fight
fires but hundreds have been released to
prevent the spread of covid
and with this many fires burning
uncontrolled it is creating smoke that
can be seen
from satellite it's drifting eastwards
producing hazardous air
across the entire country that smoke is
being transported by the winds aloft in
the atmosphere
to places it normally doesn't end up at
least in most years
making it all the way to the east coast
of the u.s many of these fires are
started by accident but as a california
couple has learned
can have devastating consequences during
a gender reveal party last year
prosecutors say refugio and angela
jimenez used a smoke bomb
starting the el dorado fire that killed
a firefighter
they've now been charged with
manslaughter
this is the american west's new reality
uncontrolled fires
hazardous air homes and lives already
lost
and many more believed likely to come in
the months ahead
patty culhane al jazeera washington